okay
so the the confederate uh monuments and
flags
let's talk about that before yes here's
the thing
most most white americans in this
country
are of british descent they were the
first ones to to come to these shores
right the keratos pilgrims the prtents
pilgrims all that captain john smith and
all those people
all right and he had an affair with
pocahontas
you like some dark meat hey you got it
so um uh leg man instead of pressed men
right so the majority of white americans
are of british descent
um we went to war against
against uh great britain and many
americans have ancestry
that fought in that revolutionary war
right and we beat
great britain which is why two months
ago
we celebrated in this country called the
fourth of july
independence day right now do these
americans
who have british ancestry who fought
against us
do they honor great britain by building
statues out here of king george iii
now and flying the union jack no the
winner does not get to build his statues
or fly his flags
on the winner's land on december 7th
1941
we were bombed in pearl harbor by the
japanese
we went to war against japan there are
plenty
of japanese americans in this country
that are as american as anybody else
and we beat japan
they have ancestors who fought against
us do they
and of course they honor their ancestors
they may not approve of the war but they
don't get out here
and build statues to emperor hirohito
and fly the japanese flag
we went to war against germany
there are tons of german americans or
americans of german descent
in this country and you know they had
ancestry
that fought in the third reich they had
to
because their leader was a dictator you
either
honored him or you were exterminated
unless you escaped to poland or
somewhere
all right so do these german americans
um build statues of joseph goebbels or
adolf hitler out here
and fly swastikas no not unless they're
neo-nazis or something
all right we beat germany the winner the
loser does not get to fly his flag or
build his statues on the winner's
property
guess what the confederacy lost the war
they need to get over it they don't need
to build their statues or fly their
flags this is the united states of
america
not the confederate states of america
the csa
right the confederacy lost now should
the statues be
ripped down and destroyed no they should
be taken down
and placed in a in a museum or build a
confederate memorial park
and place them there and people who want
to go and honor those statues and flags
go do so as part of our history put him
there
but they do not represent this country
those states that that fought
against the union were seditionists
they were they were trainers they they
tried to they they created civil unrest
to destroy the unity of this country we
are the united states
there should only be one flag there's
always like
you you speak with somebody and they'll
say well the civil war wasn't about
slavery it was about states rights okay
yeah the state's right to own a slave
that's what states rights means
right you know it's our right to do what
we want to do we want to own slaves
states rights to own slaves so it's like
two parts to that
the slavery is a part of it so it's uh
it's the state it's literally what the
business part of it right because
the people in the listen you've heard
the term you know she comes from old
money
he comes from old money right we know
what old money is right
old money is the money that came off
plantations way back then
people picking cotton bitten tobacco who
took that stuff
that stuff the white people weren't
working
they weren't paying those slaves they
were making all the money
from free labor that's why the civil war
was fought